regierungsklausur zwei tage haben sie
zusammen gesessen was wird in sachen
entlastungspaket atomkraft und gas um
noch mal willkommen hier in meseberg in
brandenburg ein guter zeitpunkt für die
klausur der bundesregierung auch ein
zeitpunkt wo es darum ging sehr wichtige
dinge miteinander zu sprechen besprechen
die für die zukunft unseres landes aber
weit darüber hinaus von allergrößter
bedeutung sind wir haben uns mit der
sicherheitsstrategie beschäftigt die
deutschland entwickelt und haben
natürlich ganz besonders die
sicherheitslage
diskutiert und erörtert die unser land
gegenwärtig
sieht
der russische angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine ist eine zeitenwende
er bedeutet dass wieder der
imperialistische versuch gemacht wird
mit gewalt grenzen zu verschieben und
deshalb ist es richtig dass wir und alle
unsere freunde und verbündeten die
ukraine dabei unterstützen die eigene
integrität und souveränität zu
verteidigen
das ist das was wir tun aber
gleichzeitig müssen wir die veränderte
weltlage die damit verbunden ist sehr
sorgfältig wir werten das hat
konsequenzen für die zusammenarbeit in
der nato das hat konsequenzen auch für
deren erweiterung wo wir die aufnahme
von finnland und schweden sehr begrüßen
das hat konsequenzen für die rüstungs
anstrengung aller mitgliedsländer der
nato aber eben auch deutschlands ich
weise noch mal darauf hin dass wir ein
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden euro
auf den weg gebracht haben um
sicherzustellen dass wir all die
anforderungen erfüllen können die für
eine sichere zukunft unseres landes
erfüllt werden müssen und wir werden
natürlich uns in der welt umschauen
müssen sicherstellen dass wir neue
freunde und alte freunde pflegen in
asien und afrika im süden amerikas um zu
verhindern dass diejenigen die
autoritäre diktaturen
voranbringen die sie führen mit ihren
politischen konzepten durchkommen und
das gilt natürlich ganz besonders für
russland und dessen gefährliche
strategie unter der so viele jetzt zu
leiden haben der ukraine aber überall in
der welt wir haben diese fragen sehr
sorgfältig erörtert zusammen mit petrus
sanchez den ministerpräsidenten von
spanien dessen land sich ganz aktiv um
eine eigene sicherheitsstrategie bemüht
hat und haben da unsere verschiedenen
perspektiven ausgetauscht wir haben
diskutiert über unsere gemeinsamen
vorhaben in der nato und die
zusammenarbeit die unsere beiden länder
in der zukunft weiter pflegen und
fortsetzen wollen das war ein guter
austausch mit einem freund unter einen
austausch mit dem regierungschef eines
landes mit dem wir eng zusammenarbeiten
und da spielen auch viele fragen eine
rolle die nicht nur militärische
sicherheit zum gegenstand haben zum
beispiel auch wie wir unsere energie
unabhängigkeit gewährleisten können wie
wir dafür sorgen können dass wir
miteinander besser vernetzt sind und in
diesem sinne haben wir uns auch sehr
dafür eingesetzt dass es möglich wird
die strom und gas und wasserstoff netze
in europa enger miteinander zu
verknüpfen
ich habe in prag die gelegenheit gehabt
wird die perspektiven die diese
veränderte lage für europa mit sich
bringt zu sprechen europa ist ein
wichtiger teil unserer zukunft ist die
zukunft die wir alle miteinander haben
und wir müssen das was uns vereint die
demokratie den rechtsstaat aber auch
unser konzept seiner sozialen
marktwirtschaft in der welt behaupten
das geht nur mit einer geopolitischen
union mit einer europäischen union die
sich darum bemüht souverän und
eigenständig agieren zu können in der
komplizierter werdenden welt
neben der diskussion über die
sicherheitsfragen die sich in dieser
hinsicht ergeben haben wir natürlich
ganz besonders intensiv erörtert die
fragen die sich für die
energiesicherheit unseres landes jetzt
ergeben dazu haben wir auch mit gästen
gesprochen und auch unter anderem
sorgfältig diskutiert man kann
festhalten
wir haben früh die bedrohung erkannt die
daraus entstehen kann dass russland
seine fossilen
exporte
im hinblick auf kohle öl und gas als
mittel nutzt um einfluss zu nehmen auf
die entscheidung anderer länder gesehen
dass gerade jetzt bei den reduzierten
gaslieferung und die verträge die
russland und seine unternehmen
abgeschlossen haben nicht eingehalten
werden deshalb haben wir begonnen all
das auf den weg zu bringen was uns in
die lage versetzt gut durch diesen
winter zu kommen und wir können jetzt
und an dieser stelle sagen all die
entscheidungen die wir in den letzten
wochen und monaten getroffen haben sind
dazu geeignet dass genau dieses ziel
dass wir den winter überstehen können
als land dass wir das hinbekommen für
unsere volkswirtschaft dass wir das auch
wirklich geschaffen können wir haben
entschieden neue terminals an den
norddeutschen küsten zu bauen wir haben
entschieden in unseren gast speichern
gas ein zu speichern und haben hohe
stände erreicht wir haben entschieden
kraftwerke kohle kraftwerke wieder in
den betrieb zu nehmen wir haben jetzt
ganz aktuell entschieden dass wir in
großem tempo und unter beachtung aller
umweltstandards ist möglich machen dass
es an vielen switch gibt in den
betrieben dass sie sich unabhängig
machen können vom gas wo sie das heute
einsetzen auch da hat das
umweltministerium großartige arbeit
geleistet und wir werden weitere
entscheidungen dieser art treffen damit
uns das gelingt
zugleich wissen wir dass es nicht nur um
die frage der energieversorgung geht
dann auch um die preise deshalb werden
wir nicht nur hier aus dieser diskussion
sondern auch aus all den debatten die
wir in diesen tagen führen
entscheidungen ableiten die dazu
beitragen sollen dass die preise nicht
durch die decke schießen und dass wir
gleichzeitig die bürgern und bürger
entlasten können parallel zu den
gesprächen hier aber auch noch in den
nächsten tagen wird es darum gehen ganz
sorgfältig ein sehr präzises ein sehr
maßgeschneidertes entlastungspaket für
die bürgerinnen und bürger zu entwickeln
und das und damit dazu beizutragen dass
die bürgerinnen und bürger dieses landes
aber auch die unternehmen diese
schwierige zeit gut durchstehen kann so
dass wir nicht nur eine ausreichende
versorgung mit energie haben sondern
auch ein wirtschaftliches und soziales
umfeld das für alle bürger grund für die
unternehmen gute perspektiven beinhaltet
auch wenn die zeiten schwer sind und
diese arbeit werden wir bald abschließen
neben diesen themen die sich mit den
herausforderungen für sicherheit und
energie beschäftigen hat es hier auch
andere fragen gegeben die wir verhandelt
haben ob die für die zukunft unseres
landes von allergrößter bedeutung sind
die berufliche bildung war eines dieser
themen das halten wir alle gemeinsam für
die wichtigste ausbildung die in
deutschland unverändert
existiert etwas das aus deutschland
kommt und dass nirgendwo in der welt in
gleicher weise
ausgebildet ist wie das bei uns der fall
ist und deshalb wollen wir alles dafür
tun dass möglichst viele junge leute
eine solche berufliche bildung ergreifen
können dass sie die chancen haben auf
einen ausbildungsplatz zu finden der zu
ihnen passt und damit eine grundlage für
ihr leben zu schaffen dass sie durch die
ganze zeit ihrer beruflich kite trägt
und umgekehrt wollen wir die unternehmen
ermuntern und dabei unterstützen
genügend angebote für die berufliche
bildung zu machen und zuletzt haben wir
uns natürlich mit dem wichtigen
zukunftsthema der digitalisierung
beschäftigt und heute auch im kabinett
dann in eine digitale strategie
beschlossen die dazu beitragen soll dass
unser land sein potenzial tatsächlich
entfaltet denn wir wollen uns nicht
abfinden mit den rankings die
international veröffentlicht werden über
den digitalisierungsgrad der
öffentlichen verwaltung der
infrastruktur in deutschland aber auch
insgesamt des ganzen
umfeld des unseres landes und wollen
vorankommen und das ist genau das was
wir uns heute fest vorgenommen haben wo
wir noch einmal sorgfältig darüber
diskutiert haben alles zusammengefasst
heißt wir haben die wichtigen themen der
sicherheit besprochen was energie was
äußere sicherheit betrifft werden
zukunftsfragen besprochen und wir haben
das in einer guten und sehr
konstruktiven atmosphäre miteinander
getan und auch gewissermaßen hier noch
einmal die gelegenheit genutzt unter zu
haken damit wir als regierung die
wichtigen entscheidungen vorbereiten und
treffen können die jetzt anstehen damit
es für alle bürgerinnen und bürger eine
gute entwicklung gibt in dieses
schwierigen zeit in der wir uns jetzt
wegen des russischen angriffskrieges
finden kinder
sehr geehrte damen und herren auch noch
ein paar gesetze von mir vielleicht
glauben sie mir dass ich einmal kurz
persönlich empfangen das hat nichts mit
der klausurtagung zu tun und auch nicht
mit dem regierungshandeln der
bundeskanzler hat heute morgen schon mit
helga wirtschaft gedacht der ja auch
dafür steht wie sich die beziehungen
zwischen russland und europa hätten
weiterentwickeln können nun gibt es
einen weiteren politiker den er heute
verstorben ist christian ströbele ein
politiker der vielen menschen imponiert
hat mir auch wegen seiner gradlinigkeit
seinem und verwirklichen einsatz für
bürgerrechte für soziale politik und der
vielen wird
sehr geehrte damen und herren
weniger anmerkungen zu dem was der
bundeskanzler gesagt hat es ist in der
tat so dass die vorbereitung auf den
winter früh angefangen haben was die
energieversorgung situation in
deutschland angeht und weil wir so früh
angefangen haben haben wir antworten und
haben ein fortschritt erzielt der
ausschuss jetzt erlaubt gerüstet in den
winter zu gehen und ich will noch einmal
unterstreichen was der sinn dieser
ganzen übung waren nämlich die
gasversorgung auch die anderen
energieträger
immer verfügbar bereitstellen und die
gasreserven die wir angelegt haben sind
dafür da dass sie wieder aus gespeichert
werden das heißt sie werden nicht dem
markt entzogen sondern stehen dem markt
zur verfügung
zweitens werden wir darüber haben wir
schon gesprochen verschiedene maßnahmen
ergreifen um die preise
nicht durch die decke gehen zu lassen es
wird daran gearbeitet das mag die seien
so zu verändern dass bei
funktionierenden markt wir brauchen ja
ein preissignal die märkte sind zu
komplex aus keinen keine
regulierungsbehörde entscheiden also wir
brauchen das mag signal aber die
senkende effekte im markt bei den
erneuerbaren energien aber auch bei
einigen fossilen energien dass die
trotzdem weitergegeben werden können an
die verbraucher und die verbraucher so
dass wir dann einen senkenden effekt aus
dem markt heraus generieren und nicht
nur die symptome ist verniedlicht gesagt
die schlimmen auswirkungen dieser in
preise auf die wirtschaft und auf die
verbraucher und verbraucher korrigieren
oder heilen müssen sondern auch die
ursache versuchen zu glätten oder zu
beheben
und damit bin ich ganz kurz bei der
situation der deutschen wirtschaft wir
hatten ja gestern bei der diskussion um
die energie herrn siegfried russwurm die
präsidenten zum gast aber auch sonst
wissen alle kabinettsmitglieder aus
ihren vielen gesprächen mit
unternehmerinnen und unternehmern wie
bedrückend die situation für viele
produzierende betriebe sind nicht nur
die großen industrieunternehmen auf die
man immer schaut sondern viel
mittelstand viel handwerk immer da wo
energie ein wesentlicher faktor der
eigenen geschäftsmodells ist da
wenn ich sage drückt der schuh dann ist
das so eine metapher die man vielleicht
früher genutzt hätte da geht teilweise
die schiere angst um den das den betrieb
weiter unter vorhalten zu können die
unterstützungsmaßnahmen haben wir kurz
geziert wichtig ist diesen betrieben
auch eine zukunft zu geben das heißt die
politischen maßnahmen so zu wählen dass
wir nicht nur den tag bestehen sondern
dass es eine klare
entwicklungsperspektive gibt alternative
energien die versorgung
des betriebs des unternehmens mit neuen
energiequellen aber auch die effizienzen
nutzen die in der digitalisierung liegen
das ist der ökonomische sinn der
digitalisierungsstrategie die wir heute
aufgestellt haben und natürlich auch
neue technik neue entwicklung nach vorne
bringen und da greifen digitalisierung
und die energiepolitik ineinander die
förderprogramme die aus richtung die wir
heute noch einmal scharf gestellt haben
und an strategie beschlossen haben
zielen genau in diese richtung wir
müssen diesen winter überstehen als land
als gesellschaft als ökonomie um dann
die zukunft selbstbewusst und stark zu
gestalten
ja meine damen und herren ich kann an
die letzten worte von robert habeck
anknüpfen weil das wie ich glaube diese
klausurtagung charakterisiert hat
einerseits aktuelle krisenbewältigung
andererseits durch die krise durch
schauen und sich öffnen für
zukunftsgestaltung und das stand im
zentrum unserer beratungen wir haben ein
gespräch zur situation an den
energiemärkten geführt dass mir noch
einmal ganz deutlich gemacht hat wir
brauchen ein wuchtiges paket für
entlastungen in der ganzen breite der
gesellschaft daran wird ja auch
gearbeitet
zum anderen müssen wir aber an die
wurzel der probleme an und um es ganz
klar zu sagen wir haben insbesondere an
den strommärkten spekulation
und wir haben an den strommärkten regeln
die eine art politisch gemachten rendite
autopiloten etabliert haben regeln die
dazu führen dass die steigenden
gaspreise zu extra renditen zufalls
gewinn an anderen stellen führen und
neben der entlastung müssen wir an diese
quellen steigender preise haben wir uns
verständigt arbeiten da intensiv weiter
was können wir tun um vor unsicherheit
verunsicherung im markt zu reduzieren
die zur spekulation und knappheit
führten auf der anderen seite die
marktregeln so anzupassen dass dieser
dieser rendite autopilot abgeschaltet
wird wir haben dann weiter geschaut in
richtung der zukunftsfragen wir reden
alle über digitalisierung wir heute hier
auch wir reden über transformation der
gesellschaft aber wir machten das
passiert ja nicht von alleine
irgendjemand muss das ja auch die wärme
pumpe installieren irgendjemand muss
auch die kabel verlegen also
digitalisierung und ökologische
transformation da passiert nicht von
alleine wird nicht irgendwo bestellt
oder ein schalter umgelegt und das muss
realisiert werden da brauchen wir profis
in der praxis die aus der beruflichen
bildung kommen ein schwerpunkt deshalb
unserer klausurtagung hier haben sehr
konkrete maßnahmen auch in den blick
genommen zum beispiel eine
exzellenzinitiative für die berufliche
bildung was steckt dahinter die
begabtenförderwerke die wir haben mit
denen akademikerinnen und akademiker
unterstützt werden die sollen zukünftig
geöffnet werden auch für auszubildende
auch diejenigen die eine karriere in der
beruflichen bildung mit einem
ausbildungsberuf anstreben sind ja top
talente und die sollen deshalb auch
entsprechend
dort werden das hebt zugleich auch den
stellenwert der beruflichen bildung auf
augenhöhe mit den akademischen berufen
also exzellenzinitiative berufliche
bildung ist eine der maßnahmen die wir
beschlossen oder ins auge gefasst haben
will ich sagen für die stärkung der
beruflichen bildung jan die
digitalisierung dann selbst wir haben
jetzt erstmals als bundesregierung eine
umfassende digitalisierungsstrategie
vorgelegt die vorgängerregierung hatte
auch so was ich sage mal das war aber
eher so eine art loseblattsammlung wo
alle ressorts zu geliefert haben und
dass das in einem chor in rahmen geführt
worden ist und genau dieser mangel wurde
behoben heute in der kabinettssitzung
haben wir das auch beschlossen das ist
ein schlüssel für die digitale zukunft
deutschlands ein kernprojekt wird die
digitale identität so etwas wie ein
digitaler personalausweis sein dass 40
ein bisschen bürokratisch an ach mensch
was macht die regierung sie will den
personalausweis digitalisieren und nennt
das digitale identität in wahrheit
öffnet das aber ein möglichkeitsraum für
neue verwaltungsdienstleistungen
und auch für neue dienstleistungen aus
der privatwirtschaft die eine
voraussetzung haben dass man nicht
rechtssicher
transparenz mit datenschutz
gesichtspunkten sich identifizieren kann
also von den finanzdienstleistungen bis
zur verwaltungsdienstleistungen gibt es
eine voraussetzung digitale identität
und dieses schlüsselprojekt wollen wir
jetzt mit macht vorantreiben und dann
ist am ende auch viel leichter als heute
möglich zum beispiel eine beliebte
verwaltungsdienstleistungen
elektronisch abzubilden nämlich die
steuererklärung da haben wir jetzt ja
mit elster schon eine ganze reihe von
möglichkeiten aber unser ziel ist dass
am ende dieser legislaturperiode
wir bei der digitalen abgabe der
steuererklärung mit nur ein beispiel zu
nennen wesentlich leichter voran gehen
können bis hin zur digitalen beleg
führung und wer weiß vielleicht sind wir
sogar irgendwann so weit dass man mit
künstlicher intelligenz sogar erkennt
was für ein beleg dass ist und der
automatisch dann in die steuererklärung
eingeführt wird also krise muss
bewältigt werden da gehen wir auch mit
großer entschiedenheit gemeinsam ran
aber darüber hinaus vergibt diese
bundesregierung die gemeinsame
zukunftsgestaltung nicht bei bildung und
digitalisierung heute zwei große weitere
meilensteine
herr minister lindner was unterscheidet
die abschaltung des rendite autopiloten
von einer über gewinn steuer herr
minister habeck wie stehen sie zu dem
vorschlag der ministerpräsidenten
schwierig und söder den eine staatliche
deckelung auf den gaspreis bei 80
prozent des grundbedarfs festzusetzen
und der bundeskanzler in der grünen
fraktionsspitze heißt es sie hätten
erinnerungslücken im comic skandal und
machten ansonsten eine schlechte
performance war meesenburg jetzt miss
berg ist so etwas wie ein neuanfang und
wann genau mündete in den
koalitionsausschuss der das dritte
entlastungspaket beschließt
france bei der sogenannten über gewinn
steuer würde mit den mitteln des
steuerrechts ein im markt angefallener
gewinn in den bundeshaushalt überführt
um damit dann zu arbeiten an solche
konzepte sind hohe rechtliche
ökonomische
und haushalterische ansprüche zu stellen
die länder in europa die solche
instrumente eingeführt haben haben in
der praxis damit ja durchaus probleme in
italien etwa gibt es bereits 20 klagen
deshalb muss man mit diesem instrument
sehr
sorgfältig in der argumentation
umgehen es kein allheilmittel und davon
zu unterscheiden ist das strommarkt
design das gegenwärtig glaube das ist
unstrittig robert habeck hat das ja
gerade auch bereits angesprochen wo wir
gegenwärtig die paradoxe situation haben
dass der gestiegene gaspreis
auch den strompreis bestimmt derjenigen
die zum beispiel mit der sonne strom
produzieren die bezahlen aber nicht für
das teure gas erlösen aber so als hätten
sie gas einkaufen müssen und da wege zu
finden wie dies im markt design
ausgeschlossen werden kann so dass extra
renditen gar nicht entstehen
unterscheidet es von dem anderen konzept
denn hier würde ja ohne umweg des
bundeshaushaltes unmittelbar eine
entlastung der verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher sowie des gewerbes erreicht
werden bundesregierung hat ja
angekündigt dass sie sich mit diesen
fragen beschäftigt robert habeck hat das
gerade ausgeführt
glauben sie mir ganz kurz auf ich würde
sagen die unterstellung einzunehmen die
die frage an den bundeskanzler
grundiert hat diese klausel hat noch
einmal mehr gezeigt und das hat das
letzte 34 jahre gezeigt und ich glaube
ich spreche für das gesamte kabinett und
ich spreche für die grünen
kabinettsmitglieder sicherlich aber auch
für die eltern kollegen und für mich
persönlich alle mal wie gut es ist dass
olaf scholz diese regierung führt mit
seiner erfahrung mit seiner umsicht mit
seiner ruhe führt ihr dieses land sicher
durch und ich bin froh dass es genau so
ist und zur fachlichen frage die
es gibt wurde drei dinge die man
unterscheiden muss erstens das was
christian lindner gerade mindestens
umrissen hat nämlich preissenkung durch
eine veränderte struktur im markt das
also bei funktionieren des marktes denn
sonst könnten wir wahrscheinlich die
energieversorgungssicherheit nicht mehr
gewährleisten da ist es so komplex ist
sind so viele einspeise vorgänger und
auch entnahme vorgänger dass man das
nicht mehr analog regulieren kann
weil funktionierendes markt ist die
günstigen effekte von bestimmten
produktion und christian hat darauf
hingewiesen dass sind ganz wesentlich
die erneuerbaren energien aber auch
kohle oder auch solange wir sie haben
atomkraftwerke produzieren günstiger als
gaskraftwerke die durchzureichen an die
verbraucher das würde die strompreise
beispielsweise für die haushalte aber
auch für die unternehmen dann direkt
senken ich glaube es ist nicht besonders
geheimnisvoll wenn man sich vorstellt
dass das eine durchaus komplizierte
operation ist im markt die regeln zu
verändern ohne dass der marktumfeld also
aber das ist das erste und das wird
angegangen jetzt schon zwei oder drei
mal gesagt und das zweite ist die
entlastung der bürgerinnen und bürger
das dritte ist
bei immer noch höheren preisen
kontingente in den haushalten zu
schaffen die die bürgerinnen und bürger
im stromkreis entlasten das das erste
was ich sagte und das zweite einer
gewissen verbindung steht also wenn man
die preise wieder günstig machen kann
dass man das vielleicht weniger braucht
das ist ja offensichtlich dort würde ich
jedem modell eine absage erteilen das
sagt wir deckeln oben dann ist der preis
sieht das preissignal weg wenn das
signal gegeben wird ihr könnt gas
verbrauchen und es gibt kein morgen als
gäbe es kein morgen dann haben wir eine
echte herausforderung in diesem winter
für strom gilt im grunde das gleiche was
man gut überlegen kann energiepolitisch
durchaus sinnvoll ist im unteren bereich
ein bestimmtes kontingent
preislich zu reduzieren und in der
spitze dann also da wo die verbräuche
nach oben steigen können den markt
weiter walten zu lassen das ist so
verstehe ich dass der vorschlag ist
jedenfalls aber nicht neu und er ist
auch seit wochen in der politischen
diskussion
zwei dinge wären dabei zu
berücksichtigen
erstens wer zahlt die differenz die
auftritt
und das sind durchaus erhebliche summen
und diese maßnahmen stehen natürlich an
den konkurrenz oder zumindestens in
einem spannungsverhältnis mit anderen
entlastungsmaßnahmen und damit verbunden
ist der zweite punkt wie sozial genau
ist diese maßnahme und bürokratisch ist
diese maßnahme und da die
energieversorger in der regel an
haushalte liefern und gar nicht wissen
wer dahinter ist ist die nicht besonders
spezifisch
trotzdem ist es ein modell das wir seit
längerem in der prüfung haben und dass
ich überhaupt nicht ausschließen will
nur es wird politisch zu entscheiden ob
die kosten und ob die sozialpolitische
entlastung so zielgenau ist dass es
besser geeignet ist als die anderen
maßnahmen die wir eben zumindestens
angerissen haben also preise über den
markt beziehungsweise direkte
unterstützung über andere systeme
die regierung arbeitet sehr gut zusammen
wie man auch hier meseberg sinnlich
erfahren konnte das war sehr
freundschaftlich und sehr konstruktiv
und das hat natürlich aufgebaut auf die
arbeit die wir seit beginn unserer
gemeinsamen zeit geleistet haben das
sind große herausforderung für den die
regierung steht und wir haben
weitreichende entscheidungen getroffen
weitreichende entscheidungen wie niemand
im letzten jahr
vorher gesehen hat dass kann man glaube
ich für das ganze land zu sagen wir
haben entschieden dass wir die
bundeswehr besser ausstatten dass wir
ein sondervermögen auf den weg bringen
wir haben dafür gesorgt dass die ukraine
militärisch unterstützt wird wir haben
sehr rechtzeitig in großer
geschwindigkeit entscheidung getroffen
die dazu beigetragen haben dass
deutschland jetzt wo der sommer zu ende
geht viel viel besser vorbereitet ist
auf einen schwierigen winter als es vor
einem jahr der fall gewesen wäre und wir
haben damit so rechtzeitig angefangen
dass die maßnahmen jetzt auch
rechtzeitig wirken hätten wir das
nämlich getan als die öffentlichen
debatten zu den themen jeweils
losgegangen waren wäre es immer schon zu
spät gewesen
ich will das nur mal am thema der
gasspeicher festmachen das ist eine
debatte da hat die regierung
entscheidungen getroffen da waren noch
nicht alle sich sicher dass wir
überhaupt ein problem bekommen könnten
wir waren aber sicher dass es einen
dritten könnte und haben es getan und
als eine regierung der tat wollen wir
auch weiter wirksam sein wie es mit den
beiden ersten entlastungs paketen
gemacht haben und mit dem nächsten auch
an dem arbeiten wir übrigens sehr
vertraulich sehr sorgfältig in der
regierung in enger rückkopplung mit all
unseren freundinnen und freunden in der
regierungskoalition
damit es ein sehr gutes und gut
geschneidert das programm wird dass die
bürgerinnen und bürger wirklich
substanziell unterstützt und auch die
unternehmen dass sie davon nicht so viel
mitbekommen haben macht mich
professionell stolz
das werden sie dann auch rechtzeitig mit
kriegen auch das möchte ich mit
klarheit sagen
ehrlich ich hätte eine nachfrage zu dem
was sie gesagt haben sie habe neben von
einem wuchtigen entlastungs paket
gesprochen vielleicht können sie das
zahlenmäßig noch etwas unterlegen in
welchen größenordnungen wir denken die
ersten beiden die entlassungs pakete
waren 30 milliarden sie haben davon
gesprochen dass noch spielraum im
haushalt 22 gesucht werden könnte und
dann 23 aber erhebliche mittel da sind
also vielleicht können sie das etwas
präzisieren und her haben sie haben ja
auch zu
einsparungen aufgerufen jetzt hat der
bdi gestern gesagt und wahrscheinlich
haben sie das von den russwurm auch
gehört dass die einsprachen die wir
jetzt haben um 21 prozent im juli
gegenüber dem vorjahreszeitraum
eher besorgniserregend sind weil die
nämlich auf
produktionseinstellung oder verlagerung
ins ausland zurückzuführen sind teilen
sie diese einschätzung und wo würden sie
sagen stehen wir bei den gas
einsparungen
kalinka wir gehen ja sehr sorgfältig mit
dem geld der steuerzahlerinnen und
steuerzahler und überlegen auch im
haushaltsvollzug sehr genau was können
wir leisten was können wir nicht leisten
und aus diesem grund ist davon
auszugehen dass es in diesem jahr
2022 noch spielräume geben wird man die
steuereinnahmen einerseits sieht den
haushaltsvollzug andererseits gehe ich
davon aus dass wir im einstelligen
milliarden-euro-bereich noch über
spielräume verfügen werden im nächsten
jahr sind die spielräume größer
da haben wir ja schon vorsorge getroffen
schon im entwurf des bundeshaushalts den
der bundestrend ihnen das bundeskabinett
beschlossen hat haben wir vorsorge
positionen vorgesehen so dass im
nächsten jahr in der gesamtstaatlichen
wirkung also unter beteiligung der
länder wir von einem zweistelligen
milliardenbetrag ausgehen können an
entlastung für die bürgerinnen und
bürger dass es insgesamt also eine sehr
beachtliche
entlastung beziehungsweise unterstützung
für sozial schwächere
der gasverbrauch
teilt sich etwa so auf das 12 bis 15 im
strombereich zu verorten sind und haben
jeweils die hälfte bei privaten
verbrauchern im wesentlichen heizen und
das findet ja im winter statt ein teil
davon natürlich auch noch bei der
warmwasserbereitung die auch im sommer
stattfindet klarerweise aber die
möglichkeiten für die privaten haushalte
in den letzten monaten gas zu sparen
waren eigentlich sehr reduziert und die
kampagne die unterstützung aber auch die
regulatorisch die wir angeschoben haben
zielt darauf dass im winter die privaten
haushalte ebenfalls ihre gas verbräuche
reduzieren um ihren beitrag zu leisten
bleibt die industrie und deswegen hat
der reform recht der löwenanteil der
jetzt an gas reduktion erbracht wurde
und der hat geholfen dass die speicher
gefüllt werden konnten wie sie gefüllt
wurden heute über 83 prozent
wurde von der industrie erbracht ein
teil durch
switch also nutzen von anderen
möglichkeiten teilweise ölkessel die
noch vorhanden waren oder auch
kohleverstromung
teilweise auch in dem man investitionen
in alternative energien oder
effizienzmaßnahmen vorgezogen hat oder
endlich realisieren konnte ein teil in
dem die produktion gedrosselt wurde also
nicht bei 100 prozent durch ließ sondern
nur bei einem geringeren prozent anteil
aber ganz klar auch an einen anteil
daran dass produktion eingestellt wurde
und
das ist so sehr es geholfen hat
natürlich besorgniserregend weil die
zeit der ganz billigen gaspreise
also einem geschäftsmodell ein
wirtschaftsmodell das darauf von gebaut
gebaut hat dass wir aus russland auch im
weltmarkt vergleich günstigeres gas
bekommen als andere region so schnell
nicht wieder kommen wird und vielleicht
auch gar nicht wiederkommen wird
deswegen hat der bus vorm recht diese
nachricht ist keine gute nachricht
sie hilft aber sie ist keine gute
nachricht weil sie jeweils in den
betroffenen industriezweigen
bedeuten kann dass dort ein
strukturwandel und wenn es unter großen
druck vor läuft auch ein strukturbruch
passieren kann
viele antworten darauf auch das ist
jetzt machen wir jemand schnitt bei
robert habeck christian wittler und dem
bundeskanzler olaf scholz wir haben uns
da so lange zugehört weil wir immer noch
gehofft hatten auf antworten auf die
drängenden fragen also atomkraft gas
umlage entlastungspaket bei uns im
studio unser bild politik chef jan
schäfer grüßt sich herzlich auf diese
drei großen fragen gab es nur land fort
das ist richtig wir haben gewartet
gewartet gewartet und olaf scholz und
robert habeck an ihrer doch teilweise
bedächtigen art ein paar der ergebnisse
präsentiert aber ich glaube entscheidend
war am ende das was christian lindner
gesagt hat zumindest was die
digitalisierungsstrategie angeht da soll
es einige änderungen geben in der
hoffnung auch dass man künftig zum
beispiel die steuererklärung noch
einfach dann abnehmen kann das digital
machen kann noch schneller als heute
schon aber am ende muss man sagen das
kam bei allen drei beim kanzler wie auch
bei seinen beiden ministern heraus es
ist viel in arbeit aber viel konkretes
bisher nicht herausgekommen sie waren ja
darum bemüht möglichst
freundschaftlich einheitlich den ganzen
zoff teams innerhalb der ampel gibt
quasi zu widerlegen wie sehr findest du
es ihnen das gelänge gelungen wie sehr
kann dieses bild aus wir verstehen uns
ganz toll auch hinter den kulissen für
dich rüber wie überzeugend politiker
viel mit show zu tun das hat heute
wieder einmal wunderbar von diesen drei
politikern auch geklappt am ende geht es
um inhalte und da ist jeder zurzeit
bemüht möglichst seine interessen auch
durchzusetzen und wenn ich entschieden
dass hier in meseberg bedeutet das dass
vieles von den streitthemen weiter auf
dem tisch liegt dass der streit weiter
gehen wird denn man will zu einer
einigung kommen aber jeder will
natürlich so viel wie möglich von seinen
interessen durchsetzen
[Musik]